hey there everybody welcome back to new
rockstars I'm Sam Bash and I'm here with
a surprise for you if you're a regular
viewer of our content you know we like
to try to keep you up-to-date on all the
most recent TV and movie breakdowns but
if you didn't hear we're finally going
to see The Avengers go up against the
mad Titan Thanos later this year I'm
very excited it didn't seem like it here
we go let me be excited there I am I'm
excited fans are preparing for this film
in many different ways if you want more
info on the Infinity stones and where
they're at in the MCU go ahead and check
out my video I put out a few weeks ago
it's a very good besides that a few
peeps online to figured out that if you
watch one MCU movie a week starting the
first week of January leading up to the
release of infinity war you'll have
watched all of the MCU movies that they
have to offer that's a lot of movies so
I was thinking why not do the breakdowns
and all the MCU movies that new
rockstars hasn't done just yet and make
sure you guys are all caught up to speed
come May 4th sound good good I'm gonna
do it anyway so hopefully you're ready
as always here just for the warning for
the Iron Man movie it's sequels the
extended MCU the comics etc etc let's
get going it's just to get you kids
excited as for what's to come there's a
pretty funny Easter egg in this movie
that does tie back to the x-men ever
heard of them to make it easier to keep
this organized for you and the editor
how's it going guys let's break it down
into sections starting with a fun one
the one I love the one you love comic
book references starting with our
opening scene in the Humvee in
Afghanistan which does look closer to a
California desert because it is I wanted
to bring up a creative choice to bring
Tony Stark into the 21st century
originally Tony was involved in the
Vietnam War and then during a retelling
of his origins it was updated to the
Gulf War so now it makes sense to update
it once more to the Afghanistan war
actually that comes around in a really
cool way later but more on that soon but
what is more fun is the reference to
Iron Man's most famous foe the Mandarin
within the first 10 minutes of the film
the terrorist group is known as the ten
rings and you can see the ten rings on
the flag in the background and this
should mean more to comic fans the ten
rings is a nod to the 10 alien rings at
the Mandarin wields who wreak evil under
the world classic Mandarin while we
never did get a comic accurate Mandarin
we didn't get a hint of him in all hail
the Kings Marvel short you guys remember
that from a couple years back also a fun
production side note one of the original
drafts of the script had Iron Man going
up against the Mandarin in this first
movie but the creative team behind the
movie decided to hold off and choose
Obadiah Stane in
moving forward to the award ceremony
were introduced to a few of Iron Man's
rogues and friends from the comics
namely he previously mentioned Obadiah
Stane happy Hogan and Colonel Rhodes
Obadiah makes his debut in the
invincible Iron Man number 163 in
October at 1982
very cool originally Obadiah was the
head of his own company staying
international you ever get a fun
reference to open eyes villain persona
Iron Monger by mr. Jeff Bridges himself
in this clip as for happy Hogan his
first appearance was back in tales of
suspense number 45 in September 1963
before joining team Tony happy was a
boxer but eventually he became close
friends with Iron Man you know a good
chunk of his history from the films but
I thought it was worth mentioning him
he's a good guy just like mentioning our
pal before Colonel James Rhodes a Cairo
D eventually war machine but don't tell
anyone that just yet his first
appearance was an Iron Man issue number
118 in January of 79 a friend of Tony
and one of the first replacements for
Iron Man he donned that armor a few
times before getting his own identity as
war machine got that Gatling gun right
here we even get a few references to war
machine as well one here when he says
next time next time but also there's a
shot of the war machine armor during the
credits the welcome for that one you
probably didn't see it you're probably
walking out of the theater then you turn
around for those after credits scenes
scooching outside the casino for a sec
we've run into a supporter Christine
Everhart yes she too is in the comics we
got a lot of Easter eggs right out of
the gate in the comics Tony keeps his
identity a secret and she's a reporter
from The Daily Bugle not Vanity Fair who
isn't investigating Tony and iron man's
connections for this movie they had to
change the daily bugles name because it
was owned by Sony you know not anymore
though she actually makes many
appearances in future MCU films even
changing professions remember that faux
news network that interview Scott Lang
from prison Scott your story is
well-known there she is
good to see you again the next morning
were introduced to Pepper Potts a
popular ally and love interest of Tony
in the comics pepper made her debut in
tales of suspense number 45 in September
1963 and has gone from assistant to
lover to hero many different personas in
fact Hera rescue Coast Guard and even
Iron Man at times it would be pretty
cool to see or Don some armor in
infinity war but you know there's too
many people there already we also get
Tony's personal Butler kinda with Jarvis
/ Asda accesses errands you remember
Jarvis just a very intelligent system
it's not great but it works in the
comics though Tony actually has a real
Butler named Edwin Jarvis who often is
seen in the Avengers mansion in the
comics eventually we did get a real
Edwin Jarvis in the MCU in a seriously
underrated series agent Carter I love
that show Hayley Atwell and James D'Arcy
as Edwin Jarvis they just had so much
charisma together it was lovely to see
them work together anyway I recommend
you checking out those two seasons of
that show when you get a chance as for
the AI Jarvis know how he ends up also
worth mentioning that in the comics Tony
is usually based in New York but
director Jon Favreau wanted to change up
the scenery a little bit from flying
between buildings to flying over
mountains and beaches also he probably
didn't want to move to New York for a
couple months you just want to stay at
home scooting forward again to the
weapons test pay attention to the name
of the brand new missiles from Stark
Industries the first missile system to
incorporate our proprietary repulsor
technology that's right repulsor which
most of you are familiar with as the
same name of the cannons in Iron Man's
Chest and in his hands next up after
Tony's life-saving surgery we meet the
man that Tony owes his life to yinsen in
the comics the character goes by ho
yinsen and debuted in tales of suspense
number 39 in March of 63 as I said
before Tony's origins changed to adapt
to more current wars and with that the
ensign in the film was changed to being
from Vietnam to Afghanistan also his
death in the film is very similar to how
he dies in the comics or sad as the
incident Tony start to build their armor
we get a look at another Marvel villain
Raza
later on in the film we see Raza with a
wound on his face that makes his
appearance closer to his comic book
counterpart but that's all they have in
common
the Raza in the comics is a Shiar space
pirate and rasen the film is a terrorist
in Afghanistan either way they both look
pretty cool next we get a pretty
impressive live-action mark one version
of the Iron Man suit sure it's not as
cool as the mark 3 that we easily get to
see flying around later in the movie but
it is still pretty cool am i right this
one can still fire rockets and it has a
flamethrower it can shoot up in the air
and definitely can't land and in real
life this clip right here Tony should be
definitely dead like super-dead
after Tony returns to America we are
introduced to Agent
Olsson fun fact originally Clark Gregg
was supposed to be playing a character
just named agent but director Favreau
and his team loved him so much they
actually gave him a proper name which
they should have because Phil is amazing
while Phil Coulson was an original
creation for the MCU this was the first
introduction of the strategic homeland
intervention enforcement and logistics
division into the MCU also known as
shield shield has been in the movies for
a little while now so you guys have a
pretty good idea of what they are but
they didn't make their debut in the
comics back in strange tales number 135
in August of 1965 this is a group of
people who work together to combat para
or super natural threats to the earth
also lil plug agents of shield seasons 3
through 5 are pretty great and you
should watch them please and thank you I
don't want to get cancelled next up we
see the mark 2 suit just thought it was
worth mentioning that the mark 2 suit in
the movie is a little bit sleeker in my
opinion than the comic book mark 2 suit
hey we get to like what we like alright
I'm not gonna judge you if you enjoyed
the mark 2 suit from the comics I'm just
not personally fond of metal underwear
on the outside during his test flight we
get a nod to a pretty famous Marvel
monster that sadly doesn't look to be
appearing in the MCU any time soon but
who knows check out that movie poster
behind Tony when he's flying around on
the streets went too fast didn't it
don't work we got your back this is a
fictional poster for a film in the MCU
titled Thing Thing hmm if you guys don't
know a thing thing Foom is a fictional
alien that looks like a dragon in the
Marvel Comics that Iron Man has gone up
against many times it's not a dragon
it's an alien that looks like a dragon
I've been corrected on that many times
but continuing forward with this test
flight there's a very special Easter Egg
I mentioned earlier listen to that plane
that Jarvis mentions sr-71 record the
altitude record for fixed-wing flight
that's the sr-71 blackbird might be
saying hey Sam that's a real plane why
you mentioned in this I'd say true but
it's also the plane that the x-men used
to save the world and this is actually a
pretty safe Easter Egg since it is a
real ship and also it is the x-men ship
they could say whatever they want also
Kevin [ __ ] you've worked on the x-men
films and on Iron Man make sense also we
finally got the mark 3 in the official
Ironman red and yellow fans rejoice
remember that harmless thing I mentioned
earlier well now we're gonna move to
something that's a little more harmful
let's look at Tony saving that town from
the ten rings what was the name of that
town town called O'Meara I've heard of
it interesting that should sound
familiar since that's the town where
yinsen and his family lived sat again so
Tony's anger actually makes a lot of
sense right now next up we get a pretty
fun knob to the upcoming villain of Iron
Man 2 listen to the names of the fighter
jets going after Tony sure they probably
didn't know right off the bat that they
were going to use whiplash as the main
villain in the second movie but it was
pretty excited to hear these little nods
also listen to that ringtone on roadies
phone
familiar don't worry I'll get to that
very soon
makes me very excited the next reference
is probably the most subtle but it is
the most important way back when Obadiah
Stane originally created a group of
assassins named the chessmen because
comics now they didn't appear in the
movies but check out Obadiah in this
scene I was just hanging out next to
chessboard these things don't happen by
accident people this is very intentional
and I very much appreciate it thank you
Marvel also thank you Marvel for the
first big not to the next few movies
that you were gonna release this is
probably the biggest Easter Egg to come
out of the early Marvel days and you may
already know it to be completely honest
but a certain Avengers main weapon did
pop up in Starks workshop let's take a
look it's freakin Captain America shield
not the real thing
they're just plans for it why is Tony
looking at that is he actually looking
at that maybe not they probably just
snuck it in there at the very end who
knows all I gotta say is thank you
Marvel our next little easter egg comes
during the showdown with Iron Monger and
Iron Man check out that company behind
iron mongers head BAM that's the Roxxon
corporation a company that has popped up
in the MCU properties like agent Carter
and in the comics they've made numerous
villains they're the bad guys
they also popped up in the
cloak-and-dagger trailer from a little
while back so I'm excited to see more of
that fun fact when the Iron Monger gets
hit by the giant arc reactor wave
Obadiah wasn't supposed to dive he was
supposed to have somehow survived like
run away at the very end Jeff Bridges
himself has confirmed this that he
signed a multi film deal and was
surprised they decided to kill him off a
B he's not dead he looked pretty dead by
the end but who knows it's comic books
coming to an end here we hear the fake
cover for Tony and Iron Man which does
stem from the comics Coulson tells Tony
to say that Iron Man is Tony's bodyguard
but fortunately it just comes clean I am
Iron Man which to me is a much more
interesting storyline for the film's
finally shout-out to samuel l.jackson
appearing as Nick Fury fun fact when
Marvel created the ultimate universe for
their comics they based their new Nick
Fury off of samuel l.jackson they even
joke about it in the comic that Nick
Fury would want samuel l.jackson to play
him in a movie now really quick let's
hit up some of those pop-culture
references ooh they're so juicy listen
to this orchestral theme during Tony's
award ceremony
oh and then listen to this big band song
during the casino scene hello then
listen to that song in his bedroom
and listen to Rory's ringtone it's all
the same that boys and girls would be
the fantastic classic theme song to the
animated Iron Man TV show make you feel
he's a cool yes he had an animated
series that I did not know about never
heard about it before today but I am a
big fan of that song I'm gonna download
it got a lot of music little nods here
listen to this song that's playing
during that scene when they're on the
plane and the stewardesses somehow
become strippers it's really weird and
dated that's as much as we're gonna play
I don't want to get flagged that would
be step on Tony by Ghostface Killah who
by the way was supposed to make a cameo
in this movie but it was cut for time
reasons I think he also goes by the
alias Tony Stark and Iron Man so it
would be pretty cool to see him in one
movie next musician to pop up during the
escape seen in the mark 1 suit for a
second you can see Tom Morello from Rage
Against the Machine getting pummeled by
Iron Man I didn't know he was in this
movie but it's pretty fun cuz Rage
Against the Machine he tried to and then
he did it's clever then listen to the
tune oppa daya is playing on a piano in
Starks house that would be a piece by
Antonio Salieri who is a composer from
this 18th century who had a complicated
and difficult relationship with Mozart
and in some stories people have said
that he may have had a hand in murdering
Mozart now of course that's not concrete
but it does parallel Obadiah and Tony's
relationship now I think so and after
that at the party at the Walt Disney
Music Hall pay attention to how Tony
forgets Christine's name
curiosity this route he refers to her as
carry which is funny since all of those
names are titles of popular Stephen King
novels again I think it's on purpose
also fans of The Big Lebowski should
keep their eyes out because during this
scene when Pepper Potts is stealing
files from Obadiah check out some of the
names went by really fast don't worry
we'll enhance it right here it says
Lebowski right up there key mystic also
quick shout out to Peter Billingsley you
played Ralphie in the Christmas story
because he's that evolved scientist
right there being yelled at by Obadiah
let's hear some yelling
and finally Black Sabbath's Ironman
during the credits of Ironman of course
I had to mention it you knew it I just
had to say it also don't worry I didn't
forget Stanley made his cameo right here
no one forgets this one Tony mistake
Stanley for Hugh Hefner there you go all
the Easter eggs and references I could
find in Ironman I hope you guys enjoyed
let me know if I missed any or which
ones were your favorites in the comments
down below but make sure you like this
video subscribe the new rock stars for
more content and make sure you check out
our panel show every weekend it's a
whole lot of fun I'm at Sam bachelor on
Twitter make sure you send me your
thoughts and feelings about these and if
I should do more of them because I would
like to and I'll see you guys next time